what in the world does Donald Trump have
on Senator Lindsey Graham because
increasingly there is almost no other
explanation left for Lindsay's
absolutely bizarre behavior he's not
fallen into just repeating Republican
talking points he has fallen into
straight-up conspiracy theories talking
about the deep state loony Lindsay or
flimsy Lindsay as some know him was on
Fox News over the weekend and in an
exclusive interview what does that even
mean by the way to call it an exclusive
interview maybe that he's not willing to
say stuff that's this crazy anywhere
else I don't know in what is being
described as an exclusive interview said
that he believes the Trump Ukraine
whistleblower is quote from the deep
state now what he even means by that is
a second layer question but the first
layer is deep state you're now a deep
state conspiracy theorists let's check
out the video you might notice that
interviewer Maria Bartiromo
has adopted this with a strange speech
pattern where she says the whistleblower
sounds kind of like dan Rather all of a
sudden I've been watching her for twenty
years on TV she never had that until now
it's very strange she became a trumpet
and now she talks about the
whistleblower but in any case that's not
the substance of this video let's take a
look at the substance of the video if
the whistleblower had a connection to a
Democratic candidate that would be
pretty stunning so the only way you can
fairly deal with this issue is for us to
find out who the whistleblower is no
American can be accused of a crime based
on an anonymous allegation the
whistleblower is foundational to what
they're doing into the house and the
fact that they don't want to call him
tells you everything they know
everything you need to know about how
valid this effort is to impeach the
president it is impossible to conduct an
impeachment inquiry when the chief
complaining witness is unknown to the
president not subject to
cross-examination well this is a really
important point because for a long time
Adam Schiff said he wanted to speak to
the whistleblower then we found out that
his staff actually did meet with the
whistleblower so now he doesn't want to
speak to the whistleblower in any of
these hearings any longer well because
what's gonna happen
when you find out who the whistleblower
is I'm confident you're gonna find out
it's somebody from the deep state you're
gonna find out that they had
interactions with uh with the ship so
let's deal with the deep state part
first the deep State has replaced other
conspiracies like the bilderbergs or the
Illuminati the deep state conspiracy as
I can best explain it it's it's some
kind of hybrid multinational combination
of people who are insiders and power
people from industry political
individuals governments who are the sort
of real puppeteers that are controlling
and manipulating the world as we know it
and as usual that the thing about these
theories is there's some element of
truth to them in the sense that listen
there are powerful people in society
whose desires are much more likely to be
taken seriously and made law or policy
or whatever than others and it's
disproportionately the rich
it's disproportionately corporations but
they take that kernel of something and
they use it to describe some very
specific conspiratorial cabal for which
there is not actually evidence and the
concept of the deep state I think
linguistically it actually was first
used in Turkey in the 90s but it may
even go back further than that but
that's what Lindsey is now fully enon on
the conspiracy theory side now Lindsey
is actually wrong on the facts of the
whistleblower as well if you have a
perpetrator and you have a victim it
actually doesn't matter if the person
first blowing the whistle is anonymous
I'll give you an example if I call the
police anonymously and report a burglary
and the police show up and they find a
burglar running out of the house with a
bunch of stuff and they find a victim
who says this is my house and I used to
have all these things in it and now
those things are gone the burglar can be
charged in this case we have since the
whistleblower multiple people
corroborating the whistleblowers story
so blaming the whistleblower is like
blaming the fire alarm for anonymously
alerting the fire department to a fire
once you show up and you confirm we've
got a fire we've got an arsonist we've
got a victim we've got a damaged
property what does it matter
that the fire alarm was this that or the
other thing you show up we've got a
murder we have a weapon we have a
murderer we have a dead person we have a
location unless the person who called
911 testifies you don't have anything
give me a break
Lindsay anyway Lindsay's behavior so
bizarre that there is speculation that
Donald Trump has something really bad on
him which explains why he's behaving
this way I don't know I think he may
just be bonkers and of course it's all a
cover-up for the simplest of
explanations Trump did it the
whistleblower complaint was correct it's
been corroborated it's arguably
impeachable we have an impeachment
inquiry with public hearings starting
today with Bill Taylor and George can't
that's the story
anything else is a distraction or
irrelevant or a deliberate red herring
or straw man and we increasingly are
seeing the focus on the whistleblower
because they can't defend the actions
they can't defend the case on the merits
so all they're doing is talking about
the whistle blower up to and including
literal deep state conspiracy theories
from a longtime establishment Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham very very
disturbing that this is how far we have
fallen make sure you follow the show on
instagram at david pakman show for more
coverage of this and while you're there
follow me on instagram at David Pakman
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blink Asst
it's amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink is calm / Pakman
if you're watching on YouTube use the
link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month that's be li NK is t.com /pa ke ma
n